shelby this used to be an orphan drug
what companies now actually see the
potential for profit in developing ebola
therapy
a lot of companies you kind of have two
categories here there are these
therapies drugs that are being used to
treat someone who's already been exposed
to ebola and then there are vaccines
which would obviously prevent people
from getting ebola that's being talked
about for healthcare workers people in
africa people in hospitals here in the
u.s the companies that are really
looking to capitalize
as far as the therapies as far as the
drugs there are really four big
companies that have been talked about a
lot that's map biopharmaceuticals
they're the makers of zmapp right uh
there's chimerics they kind of came onto
the scene a couple weeks ago when some
of these ebola patients in the us took
an experimental drug there is tekmira
maker of tkm ebola and fujifilm recently
has been getting some attention as well
and didn't techmeera's drug actually
wasn't it used to
help some of the people who were
infected with it as well yes and same
with the same with zmapp a lot of these
companies have released experimental
drugs that have been used but the thing
to note here is that monkey trials are
probably the most
um most talked about and most respected
for fda officials and people in the
medical world and only two of these
drugs have proven effective on monkeys
and that's temura's drug tkm ebola
and maps drugs when we talk about this
brennan you jump in here we're talking a
timeline of how long to where we've got
a thing in a bottle to deliver to uh
ivory coast
what most people are saying is well into
2015 with the vaccines it could be 2016
i mean these things take months to
do you have a cost millions and millions
of dollars okay but but per prescription
so is there any evidence that the fda is
going to figure out how to move its
timelines faster because we don't have
until the middle of 2015. particularly
for uh for the therapies that treat
ebola if we're talking about ten
thousand new cases away yeah they're
trying to and one thing that's kind of
interesting is when you enter a clinical
trial then the drug is more likely to be
released on an experimental basis so if
you see these drugs being tested on
humans maybe the tests haven't been done
yet but they could be released right
this is the emergency you support that
sort of so that that is what they're
trying to get to they're not trying to
get to full fda approval they're just
trying to get to human trials basic
safety move it and they're trying to do
it simultaneously they are doing trials
but then they're also trying to move it
at the same time so down the road we
actually have something approved david
harrow harris international what would
is this something that you would
consider investing in these
pharmaceutical companies that are kind
of on the front line of fighting ebola
at the right price now again the problem
is when as soon as the company gets in
the headline
whether the product's successful or not
the share price goes way out and that
value proposition is gone well that's
what's been so interesting investors
react wildly to these things you figure
out somebody gets a drug in nebraska and
boom the stock goes up ten percent and i
mean fuji photo film they have
yeah they're working on an ebola but
don't forget they're in the photo film
business which is going like this yeah
and they don't have monkey data and they
don't have monkey data and they don't
yeah it makes people really skeptical
they call it the monkey bar if you can't
hit the monkey bar
medical professionals there's sort of
desperation in this market you know i
wrote a piece about ebola ever since my
email inbox is deluged with people with
all sorts of amazing ideas to solve it
now everybody's got a plan i mean the
favorite term the ebola play i mean
there is no ebola player until you get
really something that definitely impacts
my suit maker scotland yeah but another
thing that i want to note is that the
there are two companies that have
promising drugs it's really difficult to
manufacture these things zmapp has
exhausted its supply
they're trying to trying to expedite it
using chinese hamster ovary cells
instead of these tobacco plants that
they were using wow however
i was talking to thomas geispert last
night in texas and he's a medical
professional he said when you change the
way you make a drug you can change the
drug it may not be effective if you're
using chinese
ovary hamster ovary cells over tobacco
i mean just the way that they're making
these drugs is amazing tobacco and
isolated units so it can't contaminate
other tobacco
and it assumes some kind of ramp up in
manufacturing capability as well which
is a whole different story shelby
thank you there's a lot to talk about
here